hagamos un resumen de cómo medimos el
volumen de un líquido con el sistema de
unidades usuales en eeuu la unidad más
pequeña para líquidos que vas a oír
mencionar principalmente en recetas de
cocina es la cucharadita cucharadita y
aproximadamente equivale al volumen que
contiene esas pequeñas cucharas que se
usan para el café y que la mayoría de
nosotros tenemos en nuestras cocinas así
por ejemplo puede estar indicado en las
recetas una cucharadita de azúcar o una
cucharadita de sal y tú ya sabes cómo
son esas pequeñas cucharas que se
encuentran en algún cajón de tu cocina y
que se usan principalmente para el café
más o menos así son ahora si tomas la
medida de tres cucharaditas juntas
tendrás un volumen que hace referencia a
algo que también tienes en tu cocina si
multiplicas este volumen este volumen de
aquí es una cucharadita si multiplicas
este volumen por 3
entonces obtienes una cucharada una
ah
así es que tres cucharaditas equivalen a
una cucharada una cucharada equivale
aproximadamente al volumen que está
contenido en esas cucharas más grandes
que se encuentran en tu cocina y que
básicamente se usan para sopa si tienes
tres cucharaditas obtienes una cucharada
ahora si tomas dos cucharadas si
multiplicas el volumen de dos cucharadas
por dos obtienes una onza ya que hay que
ser cuidadosos pues lo que se obtiene es
la onza líquida la onza líquida y
decimos que hay que tener cuidado pues
también se tiene en el sistema de
unidades usuales de eeuu la onza
comunidad de peso
tenemos la onza que equivale a una
dieciseisava parte de una libra y
también tenemos la onza líquida que como
ya dijimos equivale a dos cucharadas y
también como vamos a ver equivale a una
octava parte de una taza bueno esto es
extraño y por qué se llaman las dos
unidades onzas qué relación existe entre
ellas bien
si tenemos una cierta cantidad de agua
cuyo peso es ligeramente mayor que una
onza entonces su volumen va a ser de una
onza líquida así es que si comparas la
cantidad de agua que hay cuando se tiene
un peso de una onza con la cantidad de
agua que ocupa un volumen de una onza
líquida son cantidades muy similares no
son exactamente iguales pero son
cantidades muy similares ahora sí
consideramos que lo que se mide con
estas unidades ya vimos que en algunas
recetas de cocina se usan cucharaditas
cucharadas a la mejor una receta médica
se recetan una onza líquida equivalente
a dos cucharadas ahora si tomamos ocho
onzas líquidas dejan hacer primero el
dibujo aquí en lo que sería una onza
líquida ya es el de las cucharadas una
onza líquida sería como esos recipientes
plásticos que vienen arriba de las
medicinas donde se pueden poner
precisamente dos cucharadas de
medicamento ahora si tomamos ocho onzas
líquidas obtenemos una taza
obtenemos una taza
muy posiblemente en tu cocina también
hay una taza de medidas esa tasa que se
utiliza en las recetas donde te podrían
decir bueno si quieres hacer hot cakes
pon una taza de harina al llenarla
tenías la unidad de taza también es un
hecho que la mayoría de las tasas que
tienes en tu cocina miden
aproximadamente una taza una lata de
refresco una lata normal de refresco
mide usualmente 12 onzas
es decir mide taza y media sabemos que
una taza equivale a 8 onzas así es que
en esta latte refresco
déjame hacerlo lo más parecido posible a
una lata de refresco regular está la te
refresco decimos mide 12 12 onzas lo
cual equivale entonces a una y media
taza a taza y media esto es para que te
des una idea de lo que es un volumen de
una taza ahora si tomamos dos tazas si
tomamos dos tazas obtendremos una pinta
una pinta esos empaques que hay en los
supermercados es empaques pequeños en su
típica forma de prisma que contienen
leche eso contiene un cuarto bueno esto
que estoy dibujando parece más bien una
casa necesito dibujarle aquí el líquido
para que sepamos que es un empaque que
contiene una pinta estos empaques
decíamos con tiene una pinta o también
si tienes uno de esos tarros grandes de
cerveza un tarro grande de cerveza vamos
a dibujar aquí lo que sería un tarro
grande de cerveza también tiene contiene
aproximadamente una pinta vamos a
dibujar el líquido cuyo volumen es de
una tinta eso es una pinta ahora si
tomamos dos pintas
si tomamos dos pintas vamos a obtener un
cuarto vamos a obtener un cuarto si vas
al supermercado y en vez del envase
chico buscas por los envases grandes de
leche esos envases de cartón que son un
poco delgados pero tienen su forma de
prisma su forma típica de prisma ahí va
a estar contenido el volumen de un
cuarto el volumen de leche contenido en
esos empaques es equivalente a dos
pintas es decir un cuarto y finalmente
si tomamos cuatro cuartos obtenemos un
galón así es que al juntar cuatro
cuartos obtenemos
un galón y en cuanto a los recipientes
para contener un galón el más conocido
es el galón de leche por lo menos en
eeuu
a la gente le es familiar el galón de
leche aquí tenemos un galón creo que hay
gente que puede hacer mejores dibujos de
un galón que yo usualmente viene con su
tapa roja o naranja aquí tenemos un
galón de leche la manera de revisión de
lo que hemos hecho aquí hemos ido desde
la unidad más pequeña a la unidad más
grande pero podemos hacer una
comparación de estas unidades si las
ponemos en términos de onzas una taza es
igual a 8 onzas una taza es igual a 8
onzas multiplicando eso por 2 obtenemos
16 onzas 16 onzas que hay en la pinta
multiplicando por 2 obtenemos 32 onzas
32 onzas que hay en un cuarto al
multiplicar eso por 4 obtenemos un galón
veamos 4 por 30 y 24 por 28
4 x 3 12 128 onzas equivalen a un galón
así es que la próxima vez que vayas al
supermercado a comprar algún producto te
invito a que veas en qué está medido
cuando vayas y compres un cuarto de
leche vas a ver que contiene 32 onzas y
como ya hemos aprendido en este vídeo se
están refiriendo a onzas líquidas